otto diz pessoal de quem fala eu dar que
sejam muito em mim jamais de um vídeo e
o estrago de que o united funks dois
conjuntos foi muito hoje temos aqui um
modo a futebol do game é basicamente o
ar de dificuldade superior top ultra e
otp ultra musa do fluminense fred é isso
antes de começar os jogadores todos os
jogos porém já não estranha que fez os
não faz para a mãe de andréia vez um
time tão fofa atentados para 20 em vídeo
jabs
já começamos e tinha o fumo e xará que
este jogo aí coruja estava 80 o ovo por
seu pai coruja sem operar luisa acabada
portugal mas só quem gosta eu invisto
apagar a luz sobre câmera óleo cru disse
o trabalho está muito distante ainda
agora como fechado no domingo qualquer
acto indústria naval que o palácio
encantado está com 800 tranquilo ajuda a
união não é uma puma ou antigo já não
saí
bom eu ter ataques de epilepsia no meu
dedo
eu não sei o que está passando eu vou
falar a sério meu ver primeiro beijo não
aqui ou para o pedra eu só treme contar
no teclado
está estranho que belo kato aproveita
toda a gente interessante já viram ó
caiu para a qual é possível que o chá
du-ri chá
o preço pudesse agora aproveita para
rafael isto é muito então sua minha
cueca não aguenta isso nem minha cueca
nenhuma conexão nenhuma os cérebros nada
o que era aquilo que é e vamos lá
continuar e não vou sair daqui sem
passar esta noite mesmo ter que passar
isso caiu para a segunda etapa em cima
do número 10 o que está aqui em cima eu
ainda não sei como é que eu consigo
controlar 10 quadrado eu não sei em
salas por onde é que luanda vai
prosseguir agora né
o bom é que conseguimos tanto esquilo
abre o olho é pai em julgado só quero
falar só por ser palhaço tua em
mirandela foi exatamente à uma da manhã
ok eu acho que fui máximo nós
conseguimos chegar a deus nenhuma porta
assim não não é meu nem dá tempo pra
pensar a [ __ ] da última é que o
assustam no brasil começa a primeira não
conseguir um rato não consegui fechar a
porta não consigo fazer nada com que se
cruza no coruja já que importa
só que eu tenho que ter calma conrado e
o consult não conseguir um rato direito
por isso eu vou tentar acalmar mínimos
estarão canto danço eu ia lá ver o
palhaço agora - o windows
eu não sei o que acontece eu não quero
falar aqui o erro mas pronto é melhor
sem cansar né
além dos cantores fechado mas na baliza
do vitória só acalma e crack no local
mas já pagava dar 500 oeste digital onde
ainda está lá em cima na espalhado tais
só que isto controlar uma da manhã acho
que não consegui passar ainda uma da
manhã
a minha sorte é que o ovo é fácil
enganar a
tá o polaco prestes
não vou conseguir passar isso não está
mais difícil no qual ficou fácil para o
google cuja taxa é esse zé manel esta
manhã quando aparece a linha exposição
sobe muito porque tem muitos jogos não
consegue ver de todas as maneiras de
poupar agora luz porque o tubo exata é
isso aí eu ia dizer que estava primeiro
uma invasão em dublin que o podemos
porque possui um modo 2000 a cair
bora lá eu já tô perceber mas somente o
time indo zé do palhaço erro no windows
7 é muito intenso
foi muita coisa o tempo agora triste ao
mesmo tempo quero ver o oco mas não vou
deixar é porque eu sou um cristão e um
cristão num novo cruze há muito tempo
meu deus a minha quarta não é isso né
não dá para pagar a luz é exatamente o
jato sentindo o cheiro de ovo podre
jacinto já sei ok agora coruja
falta pouco são duas da manhã eu vou
morrer
está impossível passado taxadas gaúcho e
windows cancelar antônio petrônio eu vi
eu vi que o gigante é obrigando a lista
dos 100 dólares por carlos nunca se deus
não quer ser palhaço ok agora preço 10
quadrado
o zé do ovo e um dos 20 falar por favor
façam isso por mim mais um quatro da
manhã
eu preciso passar
ai vai mais mais o preço mais e por isso
mais sair do windows
aí coruja cruzam chama o jogo - o
cruzeiro iniciou o jogo
são cinco da manhã
o meu deus meu deus meu deus meu deus
são cinco da manhã também é tanto da
parceira agora estava tudo aparecer
agora são cinco da manhã
são cinco da fac manhã por ser o palhaço
agora não é o palhaço vai matar agora
mesmo com cinco da manhã dá para pagar
rap cap cap rápido é muito intenso este
jogo é muito insistiu o gato da parceira
agora na última hora mesmo quase morrer
se não aparecer um outro bicho eu vou
morrer assim tamanha por favor hora
passa por favor hora passa por favor -
série por favor por favor da manhã
poucos que passaram modo ultra defensivo
do bota os ganhos do hard do ano ipad
fredes dois já sabem quanto o fla que
foi bridge espero que vocês tenham
gostado eu sei fazer e estarão por lá se
chama os doentes fiquem bem e até a
próxima é